this is a production of cornell
university
okay we'll get started well thank you
very much again to the
cornell seat conference committee and to
you allen for inviting me to speak today
i'm very
proud and privileged to do this i'm very
passionate about this
particular topic and have had the great
fortune of
being able to immerse myself from both
science
and technical perspective in this area
of sea technology and i hope to share a
little bit with that
today with you my contact information
i'm sure this will be shared
down the road with anybody with the
information from the presentation
but feel free to reach out at any
particular time with any
additional thoughts or questions that
come up uh from this presentation
or just say hey what if that question we
get them all the time
and we like to make sure that uh i
certainly can point in the right
direction of
what may be helpful for individuals with
questions around seek technology
so to give you an overview of what i'd
like to cover today
and it's a broad topic and i know we
have a broad audience
uh attending the conference today and
i'm hoping to
uh focus on getting a common ground
baseline of what the coding world is all
about
and what these look like from vegetables
all the way to variable crops
and i i hope that is very clear and the
areas around these technologies that are
available to all of us
and then we're going to spend some time
talking about the key features of coated
seed
and i use the word coated to represent
the full
range of seed technologies that are
applied to seed
and we'll explain on that a little
deeper we'll then go into
the types of coatings used today we'll
talk about
those features that are involved the
equipment that's used for these coatings
we'll talk about that
and then finally get into the heart of
the matter of seed treatment challenges
and issues and solutions around some of
these
particular scenarios that take place
out in the real world
so to set the stage in the morning
session
you would have heard from alan and alan
would have spent quite a bit of time
talking about
processing and the and the implications
and selections and
various uh complexities around
processing we're going to spend our time
today's book
speaking around this green shaded area
which is the treatment or
selection of multiple multiple of
uh various options and inputs that
companies can put on to seed and in
particular we're going to focus in one
area
around coding and film coding coding in
general
uh the whole world of pelleting and
crusting and film coding or seed
treatment
in particular there are a number of
areas that
get involved in this treatment sphere
from enhancing
priming steeping pre-germination depends
on what type of seed you're working with
in these areas
upgrading in particular we're not going
to spend time about that
certainly there are other inputs that
are into the treatment world that we
will be talking about which are the
traditional fungicides insecticides uh
other
other products are applied to seed those
are quite important for us to discuss
and understand they're being applied to
seed in a certain way
but along the way we're very concerned
about quality and you'll hear this theme
of
quality uh throughout the conversation
today
and the presentation as to a major
concern that we will have and talk about
as we
go forward so to set the stage the
family of coatings and i thought
a descriptive and pictorial uh
description of these families are quite
helpful this is onion seed
that has been film coated with a seed
treatment on the left here the blue that
you see
and then in the middle is the black
onion seed itself and on the left is a
mini pellet
or encrusting white colored and the
green on the right which is also mini
pelleted encrusted
version of a coating on that seed and
then finally we get into pelleting
of that particular seed and and here you
have the full
range of seed technology for a species
in this case onion ranging from film
coating
through mini pelleting on crusting up to
a full pellet
now not every seed crop is utilizing
these technologies to fold in the full
gamut
vegetables tend to be more utilized in
this area
uh broadacre crops corn soybean
traditionally tend
to be just in the film coding seed
treatment area of the family of products
this gives you a a broad view of the
opportunities
of applying safe technology to seed from
a coating perspective
and within these coatings additions of
value can be added
particularly treatment and other
beneficials can be added to these
coatings that you want to put on to see
so what are the advantages why do we do
this well seed handling is a
very uh major uh input
on this area of sea coatings we're
taking something that could be irregular
size and shape and make it uniform
we might want to take small seed and
build it up in size to make it more
marketable
growers are able to plant coated seed in
various machinery
much easier coatings improve
flow ability both in the in the actual
seed plant and in the planter box itself
the growers use
and we can increase the seed by weight
to improve
air seeding by plane and then we also
have a health and safety factor around
coated seed
that it's around worker safety handling
of the seed itself
is is quite important in making sure
that what we put on seed stays on seed
and doesn't get airborne
cultural practices um very large for
certainly the vegetable industry around
coatings without a lot of coatings that
go on to seed it wouldn't be possible to
plant
as uniformly in these fields namely
vegetables direct seeded crops in
particular
lettuce comes to mind immediately sugar
beet of course is another one that's
used
quite heavily and we'll talk about that
crop a bit further
but by space planting we're able to take
care of the normal agronomic
uh conveniences that we all like to talk
about in other words
competition moisture nutrients the
sunlight
availability for the plants to compete
in a normal environment
less stress overall and when you have
less stress you tend to get better
plants
better plants tend to leave to be better
yields and then finally
with the planting perspective we get a
prescriptive seed treatment so we're
starting to see prescriptive seed
treatments
come into play by region in other words
if we have hot spots for
pneumaticide nematodes we can fight the
lava sites on the seed
and we can have an impact in a regional
area that
may not be so um such the case in other
areas or parts of
the geographic planting territory that's
going to be used the same crop
so it really becomes prescriptive and
we're seeing more and more of this as we
move forward and see technology
and we really like what we're seeing
here from the application of treatments
onto seed
as a descriptive element
where companies and particular
professionals like to get into ball with
advantages of coatings on seed and the
benefits
one of them comes immediately to mine is
branding being able to
brand a color or a look or
some sort of uh effect around that seed
that identifies the end user with that
treatment or with that application on
seed
and we do see quite a bit of this people
like colors they like the way it looks
in the bag
they like the way the seed appears it
provides a lot of
perspective from the end user and the
perceptions of quality
there's also an opportunity to do
bolt-on applications
uh with these value additions so you
might have a seat treatment platform
and you can have a biological platform
and all these can be bolted onto the
seat at various levels within the
particular coding application
and this is becoming more and more
popular as you have these different
uh opportunities to uh by the bolt-ons
and that leads into the differentiation
by our region allows us to do that very
flexibly
flexible uh from the pers perception of
having
end users do that there might be a
downstream co-op that's doing
uh seed treatment and they can be very
flexible about what they're putting on
seed based upon the region
and the differentiation they're trying
to do
the other benefit is uh companies taking
non-saleable seed let's say they have a
seed lock that's too small
and they want to make it a little larger
to make it saleable so it plants better
for the end user
that's where you might employ some
interesting technology to be able to
uh build that seed up and provide the
benefit
of that particular coating or treatment
on seeds
uh of course future additions we've
talked about that
it allows the platform to put those onto
seed
uh with these coatings and then it's a
quality platform
for the end user it just gives the right
look and like feel of what we're trying
to do and
all these built-in benefits that
provided by code and seed
really do add up in the end for the end
user
when we start to move into quality and
this is probably one of the largest
areas
within the subject matter that we could
spend a lot of time talking about each
of these areas
and really they they fall into these
major
categories dust off flow ability
plantability seed safety build up and
appearance
we'll start off with dust off dust off
is a major concern
whatever we put on to seed we want to
ensure that that is staying
on the scene we don't want that being
airborne
during the planting process or from a
perception of having materials in the
air when
seed is being treated at the actual seed
plant for worker safety
we want these products to stay on seed
there is technology to allow us to
test i'm using a hoibot dust meter
uh this is a european machine that
measures the amount of dust coming off
seat in the controlled
test the european c union have employed
this technology
to guide them in a guidance of what seed
must
meet in terms of a minimum level of dust
off
in the north american market we haven't
quite got there with a minimum
required dust off level but we do tend
to follow the european
lead um with their standards that they
have before
this toy box dust meter not everybody
has one there are certain
a number of third-party laboratories out
in the industry that does
sgs immediately comes to mind they offer
dust off testing services and you can
send seed in
or have it tested and they they will
certainly do that many of the large
companies will have these in their
laboratories for testing
products as a very common quality
control parameter
flow ability flow ability is really
measuring
in two aspects we can have wet flow and
dry flow
wet flow is coming straight out of the
treater
no carrying no drying nothing just
simply the product leading the treater
and we measure flow ability
that's probably the worst case scenario
of how the seat will perform
downstream and then we get into a dry
flow ability where the seed has been
allowed
to cure that it's it's either 24 hours
after treatment
it's in the bag we're going to take a
sample and measure flow ability
and there is technology to measure flow
ability
you'll see a picture in a little bit of
what that is
that falls into plantability
plantability can be done
using a plantar test stand there are a
number of companies that have these
for third-party testing and also many
companies having themselves
again testing the plantability of the
coated seed to ensure that we aren't
causing any problems
with the planting function of that
particular seed species and the coating
within it
seed safety the number one thing is do
no harm
whatever we put on seed no matter what
it is from the film coat all the way up
to a pellet
we must do no harm to the seed and in
the early days of coatings there were
times where harm was had
and i can tell you from first-hand
experiences that
those are not fun to deal with in
particular when you have
issues in the field based upon the
coding that did not perform as it should
have
but we've learned over the years of what
best practice
application technology materials
all this experience has really uh come
into play
where uh seat safety are basic table
stakes
they just they just are there as part of
what's expected
that seat is expected to perform it's
but inspected to germinate
in a wide range of environmental
conditions and
should also uh be able to to
withstand storage over time and have no
no harm done to it as well with any type
of coating on it
now there are some limitations when you
do some special enhancing like
priming for instance priming will over
time
the the lifespan or storage of that seed
will diminish over time
it's not to say these things are
bulletproof but we do need to be ensure
that we're keeping up with storage as a
commercial saleable product for the
marketplace and we're doing no harm in
that area
the next item is build up this is a
build
up of coding material on equipment
basically it's sticking and leaving a
residue
and that buildup occurs over the course
of the treatment cycle
whether that's all day long or for an
hour or
four weeks if you're not cleaning down
and this can be a real troublesome
problem this buildup can be
really an issue downstream we can get
flakes
of coating coming off during the
transfer of seed from one
location to another and these build up
flakes or coating chunks can ultimately
end up in the bag or the box
or whatever packaging material we're
using and that ultimately ends up in the
planter
and that that causes major issues
you've got plugging of various planter
equipment
and they'll get skips or you get
problems and it just is a headache for
everybody and we just
want to avoid those and there are some
things we can prescriptively do to avoid
build up
and then finally at least but not uh not
nearly
a a bottom feeder here this is
appearance
appearance is really a quality effect
um and in the old days we were simply
coloring seeds
uh and trying to get some some effort of
color on there to meet this federal uh
seed act for for uh seed treatment
but nowadays appearances we can make
these scenes look
so glossy and flashy and and
really have a wonderful look to them
they almost look like uh
pearls or candy coated uh materials that
we would
enjoy this appearance area has really
come a long long ways and there's a
number of elements that can go into
appearance to try and
uh spruce things up and give a good look
from that perspective so quality these
are the key items that
we commonly focus in on these six main
topics
so dust off to give you some perspective
of dust off and to try and put
some numbers in perspective we truly
traditionally measure dust off in grams
of dust
per hundred thousand seeds the eu has a
level of 0.75 grams per hundred thousand
uh those are very small numbers and
certainly uh
hard to understand if you're not looking
at them in comparison to something
uh when you look at actives alone they
traditionally if you're just being
active on with no polymer that those
actives will have a higher dust off
score
uh than a they see treated with a
polymer
uh in a traditional film code and that's
not to say all polymers are the same
here you can see that we've got two
different polymers
and two different dust results from
those particular polymers
and the reason this occurs is polymers
have what we call a binding capacity
and that binding capacity related to how
much it can hold
on to the seed when it is cured and
fully dried
don't close we'll talk a little bit
later create a fish net
on the seed binding on products onto
that particular seed and we can
over stretch that and go too far and
they just simply won't have the
capability to hold on to those products
beyond its binding capacity in this case
you're seeing that effect here between
what we call polymer a and polymer b
with the same active
loading amount on the seat
this is flow ability uh the flow meter
you see on the right there is a
traditional
flow meter you can load in a kilo of
seed
set the gate to open for x number of
minutes or seconds or whatever you wish
to measure
and the gate will pop open you can
measure the flow
and you can examine what happens after
that particular point of time
in this case this is wheat looking at
flow ability in minutes and obviously we
want a lower number if we possibly can
and coatings can help in the flow
ability and improving the flow ability
over just actives by themselves this
isn't to say actives are not doing a
good job they're doing what they're
supposed to do
but many times actives when they are
dried on seeds
they can create a little bit of a grit
and that grit can cause
some resistance and flow ability when
you put a coating on it can smooth that
surface of the seed and and get that
flow moving a little quicker
raw seed itself or naked seed that
usually flows the best and that is
usually the conservative standard of
measuring flow is the actual raw seat
itself
so flow ability easy to test there is
technology out there and equipment to
use
to measure flow ability and
and you can get a very good sense of how
these particular products can perform
from both a
wet perspective and a dry perspective so
wet seed
flow right out of the treater we can put
it in the flow meter and measure it and
you can wait 24 hours
measure the same seed and look at the
difference and you will see differences
in those wet and dry flows
plantability plantability this is from a
planner
test stand looking at singulation you
can look at skips doubles placement
there's a number of things you can do
across a variety of seed
sizes uh and and seed plates this is
corn
and using a john deere system and we're
looking for
a very consistent uh singulation across
all c types in this particular planner
stand and we're achieving that here
you can get a lot of great readouts from
plant monitors
that are out there in the industry and a
number of companies have them
for their quality assurance testing but
again
something we want to look at as we're
looking at coated seed to make sure
we're not impacting these areas of
plantability
we want to do obviously do no no no
additional
problems in the plantability of a coated
seed hitting the planter itself
seed safety germination this is a
something that we all are very concerned
about from day one with any coating on
seed
we want to always be looking at the
untreated seed against the actives and
then against the coatings that may
be going on and we do this at times zero
we might spread this out
uh at time three months six months
12 months 18 months two years and
some of those tests take actually two
years to run so we've got this real time
environment of seed being stored and
running these tests to make sure we do
no harm
in this case you're getting a snapshot
here in this graph of just a period of
time
uh looking at untreated the actives an
actress plus a polymer
and then an accuracy plus another
polymer in the light blue they're really
looking at the green and the light blue
uh effects of the coating and what
happens and here you're looking at
a warm dream result a cold germ result
and an accelerated aging result
three common tests that might be run for
corn in particular maybe
other crops um but these will be run
over a period of time to ensure that we
aren't doing any harm to the seat itself
during that storage period of time and
it's quite important we have all the
controls in place to be able to measure
these
and do them in a proper way from the
seed safety perspective so
very very important i can't
underestimate the effect of seed safety
so now we've gone through quality we've
looked at the family of coated products
i want to take a look at what's really
in front of us
in terms of uh industries
and if we look at the two basic
industries we're talking about bread
acre crops
that's the group up here on the left and
vegetables in the right there's some in
between
we're all expecting the various
performance levels
uh of quality within these crops but
there are
some very different expectations and
very different scenarios
in real world with these crops within
the vegetable industry they're small
small batches and i say small fallen
relative to what
broadacre crops may experience and
traditionally
seed seed value at the vegetable
industry has been much higher in terms
of
per pound the pound of tomato seed
versus a pound of
corn seed two different complete
dichotomy areas
within that the vegetable industry has
had some very
sophisticated equipment for handling
these small batches
from coatings to upgrading to doing very
specialized
processes to that seed to to allow
things to occur
in particular in in the seed treatment
seed coating area
there's been a lot of advances of these
areas
and handling seed ensuring that the seed
is
treated with the ultimate idea of
quality measuring
moisture and humidity and and processed
teas
after that coating process to ensure
that the seed is in its premier
condition the
opposite of that is the prodigal crop
sector there we've
had to because of the large volume of
seed that we're dealing with
there we've had to employ very large
capacity
seed coating seed treating applications
in many instances there's just no way
around it because we have to
get that amount of seed through the
system in order to meet demands and
the quantity of seed that's required um
so we have
in this area within this space of
predict the crops we do have some
very good seed treatment technology very
high level but
a little lower level on the actual
equipment side
when you reverse that the vegetable size
you have a very high level of equipment
but a very low level of seed treatment
sophistication in terms of the products
available for the vegetable industry
and that just goes to the size of the
markets and where the value is placed
in terms of acres and expenditure within
the
large agrochemical companies and what
products they're bringing to marketplace
so it's not a surprise to anybody but
there are these two
distinct differences in terms of how
these
crops are handled and what equipment is
used within each sector
there's a little bit of bleeding
occurring today of
one into the other and we're starting to
see more of the vegetable side mentality
entering into the producer crop side and
that's
very welcomed and you'll see why that's
occurring when we start talking about
issues and solutions
people have learned how to handle
various applications in the vegetable
side
and that's now starting to creep over
into the part of the crop
so it's quite interesting but i thought
this gives a pretty good perspective
of uh what we're up against so
to really break down these coatings and
we'll focus on this one in particular
film coating this is
onion and and the center picture here
you can see that we have
uh the onion seed itself and a red layer
of the
seed treatment and the blue layer of the
color and these can be layered on if
we have the ability to use multiple
pumps or they could be all slurried on
at one time
it really is just dependent upon what
technology the individual has for siege
treatment
if you look at the various uh crops that
are film coded and here you're seeing
some pictures of that
pop up on your screen you know we've got
some
carrots and tomato and various things
like that
brassica here on the left and then we
get into corn on the right
film coating is used across almost all
crops
and it does a great job of encapsulating
the treatment on the seed
and the seed size is still recognizable
you can still see
what the seed actually is
so film coating versus seed treating
today we
incorporate a polymer into the slurry
around the application
of the treatment going on seed dust off
is the result of reduction
is the result of using that polymer when
we use a polymer it's classified as a
film code
if we're not using a polymer as we did
many many years ago
it was just seed treatment and that was
pretty much done in a in a cement mix or
some other type of rotating
vessel and we just threw in the
treatment and
whatever stuck it stuck but nowadays
with the advances of polymers
and and slurries and active ingredients
we can make a very
nice package that goes on the seed and
we can apply it
and with that polymer and that will cure
and as that said before a fish net
kind of effect around the seed and
allows it to
hold the active ingredients on that seed
within the vegetable industry one big
difference that
is is very important to recognize and
there is a drying step
closed film coating or any type of
coating for that matter on the vegetable
side
that drying step has always been there
in the industry because of the packaging
requirements of managing
humidity and moisture within those
particular seed crops
for the vatican crops typically in the
past
no drying has been done there are
instances where people are employing
that technology now
and we'll talk about why that's
happening but it typically has not been
done um but now we're starting to see
more of that so we wanted to make sure
we pulled out that
little nugget to to ensure you
understand that these differences occur
within vegetable
and vital crops so we're seeing this the
shift
of this technology we talked about this
high level sophistication and vegetables
low-level treatment
and vice versa on the uh variety of the
crops
and we're being demanded to do more and
more the variety of the crop sector
is being asked to put more on the seed
and there is a limitation of geography
space on the seed of what we can
actually put on
and not cause ourselves problems
downstream at the treatment
process and and those those certainly um
can occur as we move into the next
sector and diving a little deeper in
encrusting and pelleting
uh this is more traditionally been used
in the
vegetable and protected glass culture
industries and here we're looking for
singulation we want to be able to
we want to be able to plant perfectly
in the field or in the greenhouse every
seed counts and every seed has to grow
every seed needs to be placed
exactly where it needs to go and and
traditionally this has also
been very much adapted by the the uh the
vegetable or horticultural industry
um starting to bleed over a little bit
into some particle crops with this
encrusting technology
but in general it's been have been
focused in this this area of the
industries
um encrusting traditionally 10 to 30
build up by weight dependent upon seed
species a drying step
post impression is done because we're
adding a lot of moisture to be able to
build that seed up by weight
the seed shape remains visible the edges
are smooth
we can precise load on chemicals or
other value-added products
desktop is minimalized we have seed
handling
copper books box float
advantages and we have very attractive
products so encrusting offers a lot of
opportunity
for doing a number of different
technologies on seed
that pull us in a direction that allows
us these values
here you can see some some drilling
equipment and the photo on the right
shows an encrusted product on a seed
wheel
a vacuum wheel it just shows you the
precision that we're going to get
from this that vacuum is going to pull
up into each individual seed
it's going to put it down in the ground
exactly where we want it it avoids
the whole issue of doubles and skips and
whatnot
done by this so pelleting as we finish
up
last of the of the family of coatings
pelleting is the roundest of all
products it is uh
the seed shape is unrecognizable and
the build up by a weight can go as much
as two to eight
times depending on the species and that
80 is traditionally in
small very small seeded products like
tobacco or flowers for instance
there are some very large abilities to
take place
sometimes there's a multiple of sizes of
coating or pellets
within a particular species sugar beet
comes to mind
depending on the size of the raw seed
there's been
a a movement of having a specific pellet
type for each size of seed
and that's been employed in that
particular market sector
in areas within lettuce there's
opportunities for
a couple different industries sizes of
lettuce seed as well from the coated
pelleted side
uh in that industry a drying step is
done here as well we have to dry seed
down
we have to take out that moisture i want
to make sure we get a good cure
on that pollen that's done we want to
ensure that we don't have any
issues of the seed cracking or flaking
or breaking off
during the particular processes in the
facility that's being done
we're able to load precisely uh
chemicals onto pellets
and in fact there is uh quite a bit of
layering that goes on
we have the ability to load vast amounts
of seat treatment onto
these areas these coatings and we can
move them out
the outside of the seat and that allows
some good advantages
to target agronomic issues in the field
by getting higher loads of uh seat
treatments onto
pellets it does uh does make a nice
opportunity of layering them away from
the seed some of them
can be a little phyto-toxic to see and
by layering away we can remove some of
those
uh negative effects from there we can
add nutrients and
other additives to the the coating
materials
uh give benefits to the seed obviously
ease of planting is a
stake there involved and attractive
products attractive products themselves
allow for us to have a multiple of
color schemes that can be used matte
versus shine there's a number of
different opportunities within
hello world we can do to give ourselves
some attractive
looking products
so to give you a perspective of what
these look like and it's always nice to
have some photos
this is sugar beet that you see there
and the blue pellets that have
shown up on the right sugar beet was one
of the uh
first crops to be pelleted back in the
1940s
my former employer jermaine started that
with a material supplier
and um the whole movement was to try and
get
uh seed planting or space planting in
the field to get the the prop of the
sugar beet to
compete at a favorable ability
and so sugar beet is certainly one of
the world's largest
coated seeds from a culling perspective
then you get into brassicas and carrots
and celery chicory into that leek onion
pepper
of course let us mention before
tobacco flowers tomato they're all used
in this
cooking area as well flowers very very
small seed
that takes extreme art and skill from
the operator to coat these seeds
almost like flecks of pepper that are
being coated
and they can singulate one seed in a
pellet
of these particular small seeded species
in the flower range
here's a range of
raw and coated products from your left
to your right
on your left you have carrots the next
is
fennel and then onion and lettuce and
tomato
and then a flower couldn't tell you what
flower that is but as a flower seed
and it's quite quite interesting to see
what these look like and how they
they migrate from the raw version to the
pelleted version
we then also have the ability to do
unique things within the pelleting range
uh not saying this is employed across uh
all crops but certainly we're seeing
this also more into the grass
coatings that are taking place grass
coatings are more of encrusting
but they're starting to utilize some
technologies to manipulate inhibition
and we have some hydroscopic agents for
slowing inhibition
where we're vulnerable to water damage
in cold wet conditions or cold
chillage injury issues and we can slow
the water
from inviting the seed quickly with
certain coatings then we have
hydroscopic
coatings or wetting agents and this is
to
speed the water uptake or create some
sort of a
gel around the seed and this is where
the grass industry is starting to
show some improvements in this area of
having seeds
attract the water and creating this sort
of a gel and i have some pictures here
to show you
um down the bottom in this petri dish is
a see as grassy
coated with a material that will form a
gel when it gets wet
and that gel is water activated
and you can imagine in some arid
locations where the
water is not predictable that this
offers the opportunity
uh for the seed to um experience some
some water that it normally wouldn't
have and these uh
hygroscopic or wetting agents do perform
and do perform quite nicely
the other area is splitting coats
and splitcoat has been around as a trade
name for a number of years
from a company called incotec back in
the day it was royal sluice
and uh the split coat allows for
the cracking of the coat to open up and
expose the seed to light
and there are some phenomenons to take
place um
with uh with light a light seeing
requirement of seeds namely lettuce
in order to germinate natural defense
mechanism if it doesn't seem light
it won't germinate in this case
we can employ the splitting technology
of the coat to allow the
light to get in and it will overcome
that
photo dormancy you can see on the right
how that split
basically just cuts right in half of
that seed type
and it really does do remarkably well
and there's a number of these products
on the marketplace today
that allow the splitting to take place
um rapid melting or melting or
sort of the disintegration of the
coating
very important for certain industries i
want to draw this out
there are these coatings available um
a lot of flour tobacco companies are
utilizing this technology
because they want the seed to release
immediately out of this this
coating if i click the mouse here you're
going to see what happens to the coating
you can see on the right the red pellets
starting to disintegrate as they
experience some water and here they are
completely
uh disintegrated and completely gone
within seconds
and it's quite amazing how these
coatings work in this area
and allow for us to uh prescribe this
this
opportunity and economics for the seed
to be exposed very quickly to
the planting environment
so how do we get these materials on seed
and there's a number of
pieces of equipment that are being
utilized i'm going to walk you through
some older technology all the way up to
what we use in a modern day
seed treatment application this is what
we call a spouted bed this is a for film
coating
how this works is we load a batch of
seed in this vessel
and then we fluidize the seed by pushing
dry
air up through the bottom of this
particular cone
and then we inject using a spray nozzle
the
seed treatment slurry and binders and
pigments
and the seed sort of tumbles and mum and
moves around in this cone and
the air is exhausted through the top and
captured and abated
this type of equipment is very early
early day equipment for film coding
um you can immediately see that the uh
the batch capacity would be limited
and that your capacity per hour will be
quite slow
it does do an effective job what it does
so well is it dries during
coats and so you can get some layering
if you are so
so sophisticated with your setup but it
does provide
a nice a nice way of getting that seed
treatment
onto the seed using a spouted bed
the next uh piece of equipment that's
utilized
and you still might find these today is
a side vented coating pan and this is a
technology taken straight out of the
pharmaceutical industry this is how
tablets are made
and this again is a batch process and
there's a
there's a spray boom arm that you see
and i'll
hold it up a little coat closer for you
this spray boom
has multiple spray heads on it where
each individual stray head could be
a different ingredient and it allows
uh for these materials to be sprayed
onto the seed and controlled
either all the one or one by themselves
great flexibility for application of
materials onto seed
and the other unique thing about this is
the drum rotates
and the seat inside tumbles but the
drama itself is perforated and we push
drying air through the drum and we can
actually
control the air in terms of the amount
of humidity that's in that air
with these systems and does a very
effective job
of drying the seed now this is batch to
batch
coating so you have to load the seed in
do the tree in an application but
unload the seed and it can be fairly
cumbersome
to get a good amount of throughput
through but you still will find these in
the industry
um this equipment was uh it can be and
is expensive
um pulling from the pharmaceutical
industry you can imagine that
might be a little bit more costly than
some of today's
seed related equipment that's used for
seed treatment
this next set of equipment for film
coating seed treatment
high volume continuous treaters these
these are very common you'll find a
number of these out in the
field at various levels within seat
companies
downstream dealers cooperatives it just
as a matter of where you look you'll
find these
these are rotating drums typically have
some sort of inlet
on top that allows for the seed to to go
through
in a controlled manner it's pretty much
free flow you can throttle down the
inlet
a little bit but it does open wide up
and just move through you have an
atomizer that is
atomizing the liquids onto the seed and
then the seed
enters into the rotating drum and that
drama is turning
and that drum by turning allows the seed
to
rub up against each other and by adhe
and cohesion
that treatment is pulled on and off each
other
and by the time you're done getting
through the bottom of that drum
you basically coated the entire seed
with a particular product
these are are very very common come in
different uh
lengths and different inlet mechanisms
you can even add
dry powder applicators to these units to
to apply powders to them if we're
dealing with some issues
of attack or wanting to improve the
appearance or shine
those powder feeders are employed these
days in a number of applications
and we'll talk a little bit about some
of the pros and cons about that we'll go
a little deeper in the presentation
but again high volume continuous
treaters here that you're looking at
many different model leads exist in the
marketplace
for pelting it's it's really down to uh
pan coating
that that's where we were uh for a
number of years and still used today
um these these pans really come from the
confection
industry where we're coating like nuts
or seeds with chocolates or
any other type of material or seasonings
that go on to seed
the pan coating has really been around
for a number of years
we've adapted it to seeds for pelleting
technology
there's different sizes of pans there's
uh
round ones which we call ball mills or
cylinder types
some flat pans there's a number of
different of geometric shapes of these
pants but they essentially do the same
thing
they get the seed to cascade and then
the cascading effect we're able to
allow seeds to be coated
by the operator and this technology more
than any other
compelling perspective requires a
skilled individual
and that is an art form as much as it is
a science and these individuals that are
doing this type of work
are very skilled very seasoned and have
a number of years
of experience in doing this technology
you can automate this
uh there's been a number of uh companies
that have done that
and the automation does work but you
have to have the right seed species the
right materials to do that
very difficult to automate coating like
tobacco or flowers for instance
that really has to be done by skilled
operators with the right configurations
and finally we end up with rotary coders
rotary coders are
our batch treaters that we see today
very common a lot of c companies have
these
we've got a spinning disc on the bottom
that moves the seat centrifugally around
the drum
and then we have an atomizer disc where
the liquids are put onto
the the benefits behind a rotary coating
is that
you can use this technology for
encrusting a pellet by adding powder
feeders
and it allows for a lot of flexibility
from
film coating seed treatment all the way
through the crust and repellent
the technology is widely adapted across
a
vast number of species uh i wouldn't say
you could you could pellet tobacco in
here from a from
starting from the raw seed you might be
able to pellet or
finish tobacco seeds in here as they're
pelleting through the process
but certain seed species obviously
wouldn't be
advisable to do but certainly for a lot
of vegetables
all the way up to varico crops widely
adaptable
piece of equipment to use have a little
video to show here from a graphical
point of view
you can see the seed entering here in
this demonstration
and we're injecting liquids and then
powders are being injected to coat
onto the seed and that's the basic
premise of this takes place during a
batch coder
uh is that we're able to control each of
these inputs
when we want them and for how long we
want them to achieve
the process and by uh using batch coders
it's relatively a fast
process that's taking place in these
drums because the seat is moving at such
rapid pace
it is a very quick application in a
number of areas
again high capacity output continuous
batch so the batch drops in
we coat we eject it next batch is
already dropping in and we just keep
going
until we run out of seed very highly
highly effective products and technology
in this area
there's a number of manufacturers that
make these equipments in different sizes
from small lab
size uh piece of equipment all the way
up to full-size production units
okay now we'll take a a dive into
sea treating issues with the last 10 or
so minutes we have here
to talk about some of the issues and
some of the things that we're looking
for
when delivering quality and we have a
high pressure
at all levels no matter if you're in
vegetables or bright crops
we must deliver quality and that quality
starts with
seed treatment that's going on the seed
and that has to do with seed
loading in other words what we put on
the seed
we want to ensure we have two things
that we have
bulk loading and seed to seed loading
and that all ties back to recovery in
other words
whatever we're going to put on in terms
of the application rate
of the seed treatment we want to ensure
that every single seed
is getting what it needs from the exact
dose rate
so we could treat a batch of seeds and
we could have a sample of that seed and
we could
test it for its recovery or bulk loading
it could come back just fine we just
happened to sample the area that had
the amount of product on the seed if we
took another sample of that batch
where it did not get the correct amount
of loading
our seed to seed loading would show that
difference
we want to ensure when we are treating
seed that we have two things not only do
we have c to seed loading
but we also have bulk loading so no
matter what sample we take
we're ensuring that we are getting that
recovery of
a product on seed there are a number of
laboratories that can do that testing
of recovery testing and you know
it's very very common to do in today's
world
from all different sectors within the uh
agronomic markets you see treatments
now the demand for better looking seed
that is not stock that is continuing to
push
uh the envelope we've got uh you know
these perfectly looking pearlescent
seeds nowadays
and that just equates to quality in
people's minds
and that's a very high high level of
a requirement and we can get ourselves
in trouble very quickly
by trying to achieve some of those looks
if we aren't careful
and some of those can be disastrous
and some of them can be very successful
but those disastrous ones are mainly due
to coverage issues
and within the slurries that we're
utilizing non-compatible products
that fight against each other that we
don't uh seem to get the
appropriate look we're looking for and
that occurs
very many times and that we tend not to
do our due diligence when working with
coatings and recipes
and doing our testing to ensure that
that is not the case
the the introduction of insecticides
nomadicized biological or bile
stimulants they all have an impact on
appearance
um each product has its own special
formulation each product has its own
amount of inert of ingredients whether
it be active or a nurse
and they can help or detract from the
appearance
of the final product that is being uh
produced from the particular seed
treatment plant
and it's it's really a again down to
testing that recipe and making
sure that what we do is get providing
the appropriate look
and that's starting in the lab and then
scaling it up and then getting into
production with it
as we move forward and we've mentioned
many many times about the product crop
challenge of how much can be loaded onto
seed and that's an issue because once we
go too far
we become too wet and we create all
sorts of issues for us downstream
that relate not only to build up but
appearance issues
and we have flow issues that occur as
well with this
challenge of eating too much on seed
for vegetables where we've got that
drying step in there so it really
doesn't become too much of an issue
we can overdo it of course in in the
treating equipment but
um with that drying step we tend to
alleviate most of those problems
with vertical crops we just don't have
that and so that's uh you know something
that
we really want to make sure we're
looking at
here's a a a great example on the right
hand side this is looking down the the
barrel of
a seed treatment continuous treater and
you can see the chunks of
material that were pulled out and that's
over a period of time
that this this built up and this buildup
was the cause of attack or
cure time lack of and over treating
and it ultimately resolved itself as
being a calibration issue
with pumps and that was being having too
much material applied
during the sea treatment process these
flakes were flaking off
not this big size um but smaller
versions of this
and getting into uh the downstream
product and into the bag
product uh going down to the road big
issue
big problem and we'll talk a little bit
about how to kind of cure that
so build up caused by attack cure flakes
recoveries
all those issues are around build up
appearance when we start having too uh
too much
liquid or too much product going on we
create these things called moon craters
or golf ball dimples
that's a relational issue to coverage
which flows over into the flow ability
whether it be wet or dry
and plantability so everything relates
back to
um ensuring that our recipe is dialed in
for our
our treatment that we're going to do or
coding that we're going to do we don't
want to accentuate any problems
downstream
because they they multiply and they
become large like you see here
in the building
so to tackle build up and tack uh
we'll talk about drying and that drying
can be
imparted in a number of ways can be done
with an actual dryer
it can be air time or some sort of
curing time
a lot of facilities on various crops
just have a very small footprint they
can't put in a lot of equipment
around their seed treater we want to
have
no restrictions on capacity issues want
to be energy efficient and be simple
and there's some some new technologies
that we can impart
in today's world to try and incorporate
some air time some drying around this
um in these uh photos you see here
there's three different uh strategies
being employed
in the various opportunities what you
see on the left is a rotary fluid bed
dryer
not the big blue item but the one on the
left the gray item
the gray unit is a rotary drum that has
air being going through it the seed
rotates
uh through it and moves through at a
very rapid
pace and that rotary fluidization is
very effective
of curing or drying the seed and
creating not the buildup issues that we
can get downstream
drying belts are another avenue of
utilizing
um uh drying technology to
eliminate buildup issues of such
uh fluid fluidized bed dryers again
another opportunity
to utilize there's a number of
technologies now coming through into the
product air space
that allow us to attack some of these
issues that we have
a lot of times we've tried to solve them
with powders or drying powders
and and those are while good to achieve
maybe the initial effect
the long range effect of that may not be
so good
and uh from that perspective if you've
been in a facility that's using dry
powders
as part of the treatment process they do
become airborne
they get on equipment the floor becomes
slick people can slip themselves
there's dust issues there's just a whole
host of things that can
happen with powders that go on seed
as a drying aid and something that you
want to consider
maybe trying to abate if we can by using
technology i realize we can't all do
that
uh given the certain footprints that we
have but there are avenues that are
coming out
and other potential mechanisms to deal
with that
air time probably the biggest thing that
we can we can give ourselves when we're
treating
is air time and this is a very common
box to box seed treater this is a very
rapid seed treatment application
you put a box of a pro box of raw seed
on top of this unit
flip it on the liquids are injected
through the atomizer as the seed is
passing through the auger
the auger then moves the seed treats
into the next box
so in this scenario you can see that
there's very little air time
and if you try to impart too much
seed treatment and you have conditions
of temperature and humidity that don't
line up
you could end up with a pro box of
treated seed that is very
rigid um and would need some
encouragement to flow out the bottom of
the box
so it's uh again air time is real
important
and sometimes we don't have that luxury
other times we do um but in this case
just to show you graphically from a
photo
um here you can imagine very limited air
time
just that nine or ten foot length space
of the auger which
actually there's a lot of sea treatment
happening in that auger the sea is
pushed up toward the discharge point
so some adjustments to consider if
you're faced with issues
and sort of the the
toolbox you might implore to try and
deal with some of the issues
of appearance and polymer
is one of them there are polymers today
that have very good shine elements to
them
and can also be met just depends what
you're looking for
but from the perspective of a polymer
this is where i would look to try and
improve appearance
this is one of the avenues that would be
first in the toolbox to pick up
before appearance the amount of water
that's used in the slurry this is
something that we commonly
get asked or are questioned about
when people are having trouble with the
coverage and
a lot of times by just reducing a little
bit of water
uh in the overall slurry package we can
improve the coverage
by concentrating the actual liquids
going on seed
and it can be reversed too we can need a
little bit more water to help with
coverage but traditionally it's taking a
little bit of water out
um that that tends to help coverage when
we're looking at appearance
from a story perspective the atomizer
and the equipment
the atomizer does have an impact many
people
uh using certain types of atomizers
for liquids have a basket or or some
sort of
webbing on that atomizer to help sling
the liquids off the atomizer onto the
seed mass passing by
we tend to find that a disk atomizer
gives us a
better application onto seed
due to the fact that it's just a fact of
life
we don't clean the atomizer probably as
much as we ought to
and the basket types over time we tend
to clog the holes in the basket
and we don't get a good movement of
liquids
off that basket into the seed mass
because there's holes are plugged
using a flat disc with a slight edge to
it allows us to have immediate success
of getting seat
liquids onto seed and very minimal
issues on cleaning finishing powders
mentioned them earlier finishing powders
themselves
can aid in appearance there's the
downfall that finishing powders may not
stick
to the finished product and may become
airborne or
become a dust off issue um so i would
cautiously
look at this as an area of
potential improvement for appearance but
they do work
work effectively and if they're
incorporated the right way with the
right binding capacity
of the particular polymer we can achieve
wonderful things
and then finally the actual color itself
the color
there's many color manufacturers out
there in the industry
and there are differences in color and
that just needs to be tested
and evaluated in your recipes that
you're doing
if we're having dust off issues i would
go straight to the polymer
uh look at that of course look at the
water and the
the amount of story that's being used
but the polymer is going to be
um the the tools that i'll be looking to
here for dust off
and making sure that we have the
appropriate binding capacity
of that polymer to ensure that we are
holding on those seed treatment items on
to seed
pack flow ability and bridging that
all boils down to an equipment polymer
and finishing powder
area and this area is where the toolbox
exists
for you to take a look at in terms of
areas within the facility
and and where improvements can be made
from the equipment side
maybe drying from the polymer side
using a polymer that reduces uh the
amount of finishing powder
or a polymer that improves flow ability
a polymer that cures faster
that reduces that tack time that
improves flow ability and lessens
bridging
and of course if you're using a
finishing powder making sure you get the
right amount on not overdoing it
and considering all the issues around
that as well
and then finally seed safety if we have
issues around seed safety
it's all around testing making sure that
we're doing the appropriate tests in the
appropriate lab manner
to ensure that what we're putting on is
done in advance of tests
so that we can be assured that we hit
the facility and the seed processing
plant
that we are doing no harm to the seed
so these are some of the tools that i'd
pull out when looking at a problem
and employing multiple strategies and it
takes
multiple strategies to overcome problems
in the facilities that we're working
and with on i think we're just about on
time for you alan
oh peter this this is perfect uh thank
you so much for your
your great presentation and overview of
all these modern sea technologies seed
coating technologies and seed treatment
technologies
i want to open it up please if you have
a question just
unmute and ask or you could use the chat
and type in
uh your question there
can you go to the last your lap last
slide for that cca there we go
so again those of you that want the cca
credits
that is the information for you on the
cca
credits for for peter's talk
but again i want you to make sure any
questions
a lot of information to assimilate and
things like that
to process before they may be able to
even ask a question i know i've
taken notes as we're talking as well big
big subject matter i know
i'd like to just congratulate peter on a
great presentation it's always
interesting i see a lot of these topics
but
from our standpoint a little bit more
from the field crops of the broad acre
crops as you're
referring to them whereas peter's coming
some from the vegetable side so it's
always interesting to see the
differences in the issue
i always say that i tend to look at the
vegetable crops other specialty seeds to
find out what's coming next
what's going to hit us the fluidized bed
dryers are showing up
sometimes the one surprising things i
see them often in soybean maybe more
than corn uh certainly in cottonseed
where they've got real high application
rates but the soybeans don't tend to
soak up the soy seed the water as well
they just don't really like water that
much and so sometimes you see
things used that you wouldn't expect
would ever
perhaps be economically viable but if
it's if there's enough volume involved
and it can solve problems
sometimes you know it's like getting a
big hammer to make sure the problems
taken care of but
i i am seeing some of the same trends
that that you're showing in there so
thank you alan
any any other questions yeah this is uh
bob king
uh and we keep hearing a lot about how
uh weather and the climatic change and
all that's have an impact or potentially
could have an impact
the what type of impact could you see on
these technologies
that's a great question that that is a
a real factor so if you can imagine
soybeans being stored in
silos outdoors under very cold
conditions
and moving them into the seed treatment
process
there is a an adjustment that's made for
that during the seed treatment process
to ensure that recipe
is appropriate we see later in the
season when the beans warm up
and they enter the seed treatment
process that whole recipe changes
and the the curing or the attacking that
occurs
that dynamic moves dramatically uh
from that that warming of the seed
and so as our as our conditions change
over the treating season we do see a
difference of recipe
adjustments to being need to make being
have to make make
make them and it's just
with climate change and what's occurring
we see more swings throughout that
season than we have ever before
and so i think we're going to have to
employ
different strategies throughout the
season in order to overcome those
obstacles that we that we see from the
environment
in controlled environments like a
vegetable processing facility where
we're dealing with seed and small lots
that are that are more
environmentally controlled we really
don't see those issues but with
particular crops we're storing vast
amounts of seeds
in basically environmental conditions
that are different
uh in almost ambient in cases we are
experiencing those differences so it
has to be employ a different strategy
throughout the year for that
thank you okay
peter this is uh this is mike migliazzo
um would you foresee an opportunity
um for in the polymer industry
to tailor uh properties for polymers
that have different film forming
characteristics for these weather to
address some of the weather conditions
that seeds are being treated in any time
between like
some people treating december some treat
in may
um yeah yeah
that's exactly right mike and uh thanks
for the question
and and we do see that and we are seeing
some
some asks around binding capacity
to adjust that binding capacity to
match the environmental condition the
problem is we can't predict it
and we could run ourselves into a little
bit of an issue
one way or the other on that knife edge
of an area
but there are small tweaks we can do
within that polymer space to allow us
tweaks of the binding capacity of the
same product to give the same look
but to change the overall dynamics of
the
rheology of the product
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu